one of my questions for you is uh we've
seen a number of data points that are
starting to suggest
uh the rest of the world is waking up to
us maybe being in a recession we saw the
the fed now uh or the uh fed gdp or gdp
now whatever the hell they call the
thing uh the atlanta fed uh
it went from like i think it's gonna be
a positive gdp reading to negative real
quick i think it was last week
what's your take on
the time that it takes
for us to actually see data points
that will give more and more people in
the market confidence that we are
actually in the recession like it's not
like we have real time data so how do
you think about the time that needs to
expire
for people to internalize we are headed
towards worse and worse financial
conditions
oh that's a great question man big time
question um so i'll start by saying the
u.s economy at least according to
atlantis fed's models and other
models that are somewhere similar nature
now casting models we are in a what we
call a technical recession in the
economics community that's where you
have two consecutive quarters of
negative gdp growth headline gdp growth
we are not in an actual recession and
what i mean by actual recession is sort
of how the nber the national bureau of
economic research defines it um and this
is the organization that really just
determines our recessions how they
define it is sort of a you know
statistically significant downside
deviation and output you know it can be
measured across you know different
industries and you know industry
manufacturing sectors et cetera et
cetera income et cetera that is very
clearly not happening um if you look at
uh that first chart i don't know if you
got the charts i sent you but um the
first try to send you is the uh the u.s
economy is not likely in an actual
recession yet and what this chart just
shows is our initial jobless claims um
you know pretty famous statistic as this
is you know people applying for
unemployment insurance um usually after
losing their job
and the reality is you know we're back
we're taking up off the lows but neither
this sort of rate of change nor the
level would imply that we're actually in
a you know significant you know sort of
um
decline in labor demand and significant
decline in total employment so uh i
would dismiss the atlanta fed this uh
sort of um projections as sort of more
kind of noise what will be the real
signals as we you know progress
throughout q3 and into q4 is when you
know measures like initial jobless
claims total employment non-bond
payrolls when those really start to slow
alongside things like pmis that'll be
your real clear indication uh that we're
actually into or heading into a
quote-unquote actual recession
when you see this
is it important the technical kind of
definition
like does that actually matter or does
that just give people something to talk
about on the internet but but it's less
important
yeah 100 percent it's just noise this is
this is what gives people a fodder for
finn twit to go back and forth on what
they speculate the fed may or may not do
but the reality is the fed one is not
looking at stuff like you know the
atlanta fed gdp now cast to determine
policy right you know the fed is looking
at you know this whole host of
compendium uh
compendium of indicators particularly
focused on inflation in the labor market
to um to determine what that uh what
that what that stuff is and when you
look at the labor market i set you
another chart the labor market is
cooling rapidly but not rapidly enough
you know the labor market is still white
hot like we're like we are nowhere near
a recession in labor market terms uh
which is you know clearly one of the the
main statistics you're going to need to
determine if we're in recession and so
what i mean by this i'll explain the
chart um so the the light blue bars or
sort of where the different metrics um
you know where they average throughout
2015 2019 so kind of the baseline trend
the gray bar is the prior month's data
and the dark blue bars the most recent
month data i'll draw your eyes to the uh
the second cluster of bars and the final
cluster of bars the second cluster bars
just shows other trend and average
hourly earnings for the private sector
at five point six percent we're
literally running at a double on a
three-month annualized rate of change
basis than we did in the sort of on the
baseline period which is the light blue
bar um the the the fourth cluster just
shows uh private sector at this sort of
aggregate income when you sort of um you
do the product of uh hours worked wages
and then total employment you know at
eight percent on a three-month
annualized basis were you know more or
less a double in terms of where the
labor market was running on a trend
basis through 2019 so this labor market
is not only not in recession it is
basically as
growing as fast as it's been in recent
years by basically a factor of two and
so the fed is paying attention to data
like this that's telling you
they're eventually gonna break they're
gonna continue tightening until they
break something so when i think of uh
the labor market there's i don't know 10
and a half 11 million open jobs in
america most uh or around the most that
there's ever been uh unemployment is uh
near historic lows uh sitting at 3.5 or
whatever which still is higher because i
think it was 3.4 in february of 2020 if
i remember correctly uh but you know
generally the same um
we saw this week i think that the data
just came out there was like a 4 000 uh
increase in jobless claims
which was a little bit higher than uh
than the consensus was expecting it came
in at like 235 000 or something like
that um when you think of all that
the first thing that jumps to mind is
why is there so many open rolls
why why is in uh unemployment so low if
anecdotally we see companies preparing
for a recession they're starting to do
hiring freezes they're starting to do
layoffs like is this just we're early in
this process and we should expect
unemployment to go up larry summers a
former treasury secretary claims that we
need five years of five plus percent
unemployment to bring inflation down uh
like how do you kind of think about that
yeah that's a that's a very draconian
forecast we're definitely not in that
camp and we certainly don't see the
leveraged cycle dynamics to get you to
an outcome like that you'd basically
have to have the fed go a wall in order
to get there but you know in terms of
why there's so many open jobs in the
country one there's a there's a few
reasons right we've seen a so what the
economists are calling this sort of
quote unquote great resignation where
you've seen as a lot of folks who you
know because of the financial crisis
because of the dot-com bursting of the
bubble um they were unable to retire at
least according to their initial plan so
they were effectively working for longer
than they anticipated um obviously we're
continuing to have better health
outcomes generally speaking um for most
most cohorts in the society so people
have been working longer and so what
we've seen is a pretty significant
reduction um in the labor force
participation rate for sort of you know
the elderly cohorts you know 55 plus um
in this um in this cycle we've also seen
a broad-based reduction in female labor
force participation is rate as well you
know obviously the sort of change in
covet during covet obviously a lot of um
you know sort of females have to help
you know sort of
call it upon to to help raise kids
incrementally with schools being closed
et cetera but i also think there's
another factor to that as well which is
you know you have people moving from
high cost cities to lower cost
residential areas suburban areas where
you no longer need sort of two whole
incomes to support uh to support
families so there's been a significant
reduction in the total number of people
available at the same time while the
economy is growing on a nominal basis
eight ten percent you know very quick
you know very fast and so clearly the
companies are scrambling to sort of meet
the demand for their customers and new
orders which by the way are falling off
a cliff if you look at the ism surveys
um you know so that's that's why we see
this sort of big big thing a job in in
joe's big big sort of uh
lofty level in jolts but there's one
chart i did want to sort of conclude
with uh which is something uh you know i
think is really important in the context
of the fed's framework which is the fed
will tighten into it break something
labor demand and this chart just shows
the um the ratio of jolt's total job
openings relative to the total number of
unemployed workers and we're starting to
move down which is what jay powell's
explicitly called out is something he
wants to achieve which is getting this
thing back into equilibrium which is
somewhere around one you know job
opening per one person unemployed that
would bring in theory the labor market
into uh to some study of equilibrium
we're coming off the all-time high there
but we're not moving down fast enough
nor have we achieved a level or
threshold that would tell the fed that
its job is done here so they're ju you
know i think the markets are saying okay
we're moving in the right direction
markets tend to function a rate of
change but the fed is an academic
institution that functions on levels and
thresholds and right now from a level
threshold perspective we are still very
hot very much overheating in the labor
market again even looking at this
statistic by a factor of two